[APPLAUSE]
DIANE GREENE: Hi, everybody.
I'm Diane Greene.
I run Google's phenomenal Cloud.
I'm on the board of Alphabet,
and I'm incredibly proud today
to be here moderating this
panel of just absolute leading
experts, leading
researchers, and experts
in artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
We're going to
structure our panel
talking about past,
present, and future, closing
with some personal
reflections on the industry
and our careers.
And before I do
that, I'm just going
to quickly introduce everybody.
First is Francoise Beaufays.
She's principal
scientist at Google
and is the leader of speech
recognition at Google,
something everybody uses.
[APPLAUSE]
Been at Google 12 years.
Second is Fei-Fei Li.
She's the chief scientist
of Google Cloud.
[APPLAUSE]
Bringing AI and ML to
companies all over the world,
also head of Stanford's
AI Lab, and inventor
of imageNet and
imageNet Challenge,
which really contributed
to some of our developments
in deep learning and AI.
And she's also a
champion of STEM and AI
and the founder of AI for All.
Next, Fernanda Viegas?
She's a senior staff
researcher at Google,
she's a computational
designer, she
focuses on the scientific
and collaborative aspects
of information visualization,
co-leads the Big Picture data
visualization group, she's
part of Google Brain,
and she's also known for her
visualization-based artwork,
which is part of the permanent
collection of the Museum
of Modern Art in New York.
[APPLAUSE]
And then, let me introduce
Daphne Koller, who
today is chief computing officer
at Calico, Calico Labs, which
is a part of Alphabet,
working to give people
longer and healthier lives.
She spent 18 years at Stanford--
she led the AI group
there, she cofounded
Coursera, which is the
largest platform for MOOC's
massively online courses--
open online courses.
And you know, Daphne was
one of "Time Magazine's"
100 most influential
people in 2012,
she won a MacArthur
Foundation award,
she won the inaugural
ACM prize for computing,
she's a member of the Academy of
Arts and Sciences, the Academy
of Engineering--
and those are just
some of the proof points
of her excellence.
[APPLAUSE]
So we'll start with a
historical perspective.
And Daphne, as one of the most
prominent and prolific authors
of machine learning
research papers,
can you give us your
perspective on how we've
transitioned to deep learning?
DAPHNE KOLLER: So I think
the deep learning revolution
is a truly exciting enabler
that we're seeing today
in so many aspects of so
many real world problems.
But that revolution
came out of an outgrowth
of a lot of machine learning
research that lead up to it.
So prior to deep learning,
there were probably
about 10 or 15 years of very
hard work in developing models
that were maybe
more hand-crafted
that required a lot more thought
and a lot more prior knowledge.
And we really had to sync
through the specifics
of the model and how it
relates to the domain.
Because when you don't
have a lot of data,
you have to replace that
with a lot of human intuition
on how the model ought
to be constructed.
As we've gotten more and
more data in certain domains,
text and images being I think
the two prime examples--
and speech of course, as well--
we've started to replace a lot
of that need for human insight
with more and more data
that counterbalances that.
But the techniques that were
developed in those 10 or 15
years are still pivotal
today, both in the methods
themselves-- those optimization
algorithms that were developed
over the last 10 or
15 years are still
a key component of what enables
deep learning to be successful.
And I think that
while we might like
to think that big
data is at this point
the solution to everything, it's
a solution in certain domain
areas but, in others, we
still are unfortunately
in the medium or sometimes
even small data regime.
And so they're still
definitely a need
for balancing human intuition
about the domain with the data
that were acquiring and
coming up with a model that
incorporates the best of both.
DIANE GREENE: Thank you.
And Fei-Fei, can we also
get your perspective?
You're running the
Stanford AI Lab,
your imageNet work was seminal,
and now you're bringing--
you're looking at bringing AI
to every company in the world.
What is going on
with that transition?
FEI-FEI LI: Right.
Thank you, Dianne.
So just a little bit of
a historical perspective
that AI in all sciences
of human civilization
is actually a very young field.
We're about 60 years old,
but the very question
of the quest for
intelligence, in my opinion,
is what's at the root
of AI's inspiration.
And that dates back
since the beginning
of the dawn of civilization.
So about 60 years ago,
when machines started
to compute and
calculate at that time
very simple arithmetics, already
thinkers like Alan Turing
challenged humanity with the
question, can machines think?
Can machines have intelligence?
So about 60 years ago,
leading computer scientists
like Marvin Minsky, Joe
McCarthy, and many others
got together and really
jump-started the field
that today we know as AI.
The AI that the
founding fathers saw
was very different
technically 60 years ago.
But it was the same core
dreams which is making machines
to learn, to reason, to
think, to perceive, to speak,
to communicate.
And AI has gone through several
waves of technical development,
from first order logic
to experts systems
to the early waves of
machine learning to today--
the deep-learning revolution.
I would say the past 60 years,
I call it the in-vitro AI,
or AI in-vitro.
It's the 60 years
there, as a field,
we laid the foundation
of the questions we ask,
the sub-fields that are
essential to AI's quest like,
robotics, computer vision,
natural language processing,
speech processing, [? comp ?]
[? bio, ?] and so on.
But also the way we measure the
progress to understand our data
and discover the tool sets.
So around 2010, around that
time, thanks to the convergence
of the maturing of statistical
machine learning tools,
the convergence of
big data brought to us
by the internet,
and by the sensors,
and the convergence of computing
that Moore's law carried us
to much better hardware.
These three pillars
came together
and lifted AI from
the in-vitro stage
into what I call
the in-vivo stage.
AI in-vivo is where AI is making
a real impact to the world.
It's just the beginning.
Every single industry
at Cloud, at Google,
we see is going through a
transformation because of data,
because of AI, and
machine learning.
And this is what I see
as the historical moment
that AI is going to impact
and transform the field.
But I also do want to say
it's just the beginning.
The tools and the
technologies we
have developed in
the field of AI
is really the first few drops
of water in a vast ocean of what
AI can do.
We cannot over-promise this,
but there should be tremendous
excitement that we can do, a lot
more work to do to make this AI
in-vivo happen
DIANE GREENE: I share
your excitement.
This in-vivo state,
I mean companies
are putting virtual renditions
of themselves in the cloud
and then they're using AI to
do things nobody ever thought
was possible.
And AI's being used everywhere,
not just in the cloud.
So thank you.
If we dive a little
deeper, Francoise,
you've been at the frontier
of speech recognition and now
in applications,
speech recognition
is actually becoming
almost commonplace.
Can you take us through
that transition?
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS:
Yes, certainly.
So I joined Google
about 12 years ago.
And a bunch of us
came with this vision
of doing something useful and
fun with speech recognition.
Speech recognition had been
around for quite awhile.
All of us had some
background in the field,
but we wanted to
do something fun.
And that was hard because speech
wasn't the quality it is now.
So we started with
fairly limited products
where the task of recognizing
what the person says
wasn't too, too complicated.
We were just trying to push
the envelope a little bit
but not much.
Because we needed to
bring it to a place
where the product was successful
enough that people would want
to use our application,
and then we
could start folding
data into the models
and keep it trading from there.
So we built what
we called GOOG-411.
I don't know if any
of you remembers that,
but it was just a
phone application.
You would call a number,
and then it would say, hey,
what city and state?
And you would say what
you were interested in,
and then it would ask
about the business
that you were interested in.
You would say that
name, and then it
would offer to connect you
to that business in that city
and state.
So again, picture that
it's 12 years ago.
There's no iPhone,
no Android phone,
all you have is that little flip
phone that you put to your ear.
So it was very basic.
Fortunately,
leadership at Google
was really visionary
about this technology
and really encouraged us
to push the boundaries
as much as we could.
And so we were successful
with this first application.
But then, the iPhone
and the Android phone
came, so everything
changed, obviously.
Now there was visual feedback.
So we started thinking
about other applications,
and that was voice search--
so Google search by voice.
And then we started doing
dictation and having
a little microphone in
every possible entry
point in your phone, so
you could do everything
with your voice.
And more recently,
we've moved into trying
to enable speech
recognition within your home
with devices like Google Home.
And because people are asking
for more and more tasks
to be fulfilled through voice,
that was a really good entry
point into the whole
assistance story, where instead
of just enabling you to do very
small things with your voice.
Now you can ask questions,
you can phrase them
in natural language,
you can get really
Google to be your assistant
without this cumbersome
physical keyboard input.
DIANE GREENE: Thank you.
Fernanda, you said you
wanted democratized data
visualization, and that's sort
of inextricably linked to data.
How did you get to that?
What are the needs you see for
data visualization analytics?
And how's that evolved?
FERNANDA VIEGAS:
Yeah, so I started
working in data visualization
over 10 years ago.
And when I did, it
was much different.
It was much harder to
do data visualization,
the machines were
not nearly as good,
and there wasn't as
much data out there
that was publicly available.
That started to
change, and now we
find ourselves in
an environment where
people are interacting
with data visualization
sort of everywhere.
It's really exciting.
It's been amazing to
see, like, journalism
take on data
visualization and talk
about really
complex stories when
they talk about statistics.
We always joke that
data visualization
is sort of that gateway
drug to statistics.
It's like you're
doing statistics
without even noticing that
you are, because we're just
visually so good at picking
up patterns and outliers
and so forth.
So data visualization
has been on this trend
of becoming more democratized.
And also, I really
believe that people have--
we have been increasing
people's ability
to take in data and numeracy.
And so data visualization has
had a role to play in that.
In terms of AI, it's
been really interesting.
Because we saw a major jump
when Geoff Hinton and colleagues
proposed the first sort of
blockbuster visualization
for AI, t-SNE.
It's a technique
that allows you--
so one of the big challenges
with AI and with machine
learning is that these are
systems that work in very
high dimensional spaces.
And those are really hard for
us as humans to understand.
So visualization is one way
that you can sort of peak
and try to understand what's
happening in these systems.
And these techniques, such
as the one that Geoff Hinton
developed, allows us--
they allow us to
sort of understand
how things are
clustering together,
what are the relationships
between different concepts,
and how the systems are sort
of resolving the data that they
are ingesting.
So I'd say that was a major--
there was major progress,
and the beginning--
as Fei-Fei was saying,
I feel like were also
in the beginning of this
relationship between how
visualization can help AI.
DIANE GREENE: Thank you.
Now we're going to switch to
a slightly more technical set
of answers to what's
going on in the present.
Francoise, maybe
we'll start with you
and talking about speech
recognition technologies,
and what have the
transitions been,
and what were the challenges,
and what are they today.
How have the challenges evolved?
Yeah.
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: Yeah, sure.
So speech recognition is
really complex, right?
It's difficult to recognize
what you're saying.
Each one of us has a different
voice, has a different accent.
We're speaking in
different environments.
So all that contributes to
the richness of the voice.
And I think mostly
for that reason,
speech recognition has always
been based on machine learning.
There hasn't been,
or not much of,
an earlier phase that was
in machine learning base.
It's just that type
of machine learning
has been evolving over time.
And we kept making progress in
the field for the last three
decades, but I
think one inflection
point has been the adoption
of neural networks.
And that has happened maybe
eight years ago or so,
maybe a little bit less.
But the early research
in speech recognition
using neural networks
happened a long time before.
There was a lot of
activity in the field.
There were a lot of
promising results;
however, there wasn't
the complete support
to really make it happen.
And so neural nets were a
little bit abandoned for awhile,
and speech recognition
kept improving
with more basic methods
like Gaussian Mixer
Models and whatnot.
And then, when we started really
evolving into deep neural nets,
it was a big effort from
an engineering viewpoint.
We had to deal with
latency issues,
with size, with training
capabilities, and so on.
And eventually, when
deep neural networks
became a reality, when we
launched them when we really
had them in production,
that opened the path
to a whole bunch of
other improvements.
Because now, we
had the capability
of having that complex machinery
there behind the technology.
And so we could
move very quickly
from one neural
architecture to the next.
And so we started looking into
recurrent neural networks,
such as LSTM, we looked into
convolution neural networks--
and so CTC-based
sequence modeling--
we have a whole bunch
of sequence modeling
new implementations coming up.
With Google Home, we have
the neural beam forming.
And so essentially,
what's happening
is that the moving
to the neural network
space has opened this
incredible capability
for innovating the
core technology that
powers our systems and
keep optimizing and giving
all of you, in whichever
language you're speaking,
the best possible
accuracy we can.
DIANE GREENE: OK, well neural
nets for speech recognition
to neural nets for extending our
lives and making us healthier.
A fairly open-ended
question for you, Daphne--
why does Calico need one of the
top researchers in the world
in molecular biology--
you know, biological computing,
and also machine learning?
As the chief computing officer,
what are you doing over there?
DAPHNE KOLLER: So
many of you may not
know of Calico
because we've been
a little bit under the radar.
So Calico is one of the Alphabet
companies, the first one that
was spun out of Google.
And it aims to understand
the problem of aging
and to help people live
longer and healthier lives.
Now when you look at
aging, you realize
that it's actually the single
largest risk factor for death.
And I know that seems kind of
funny when you think about it,
but it's true for almost
every disease that
happens after the age of 40.
That as you grow
older, year after year,
the risk from that disease
increases exponentially
every year, whether
it be diabetes
or cardiovascular
disease, or cancer.
All of these increase
exponentially.
No one knows why that is.
Why is it that every year
of life after the age of 40
puts us at an increased risk
for each of those diseases?
And in order to
understand that, we really
need to study the
biological systems
that exhibit aging at
the molecular level
all the way through
the systems level
and figure out what it is
that's causing us to age.
Because I don't think
we'll live forever,
but maybe we can live longer
and healthier by interventions.
One of our earliest
scientists, Cynthia Kenyon,
who came over to
Calico from UCSF,
showed that with a
single gene mutation
in the nematode C. elegans,
you can extend its lifespan
by something like 30% to 50%.
And not only does
the worm live longer,
it lives as if it were a
healthy, young worm in terms
of reproductive health,
and movement, and so on.
So can we do
something like that?
That would allow humans
to live healthier?
So that would be really cool,
but in order to do that,
there's a whole lot of
understanding that we still
need to gain.
And in order to do that,
we need to gather data
about all of those
systems, all of which age.
Yeast age, worms age,
flies, mice, humans--
what is it that we all have in
common at the molecular level?
So fortunately, scientists have
been able, over the last 20
years, to devise a whole slew
of measurement modalities
that allow us to get an
understanding, or at least
data, regarding
systems as they age.
And that includes
techniques like sequencing
and microfluidics at the
low level, and imaging,
all the way through
to things like devices
that track movement
and allows wearables
to track movements and see how
systems change as they age.
But no human being
has the capability
to put together data at these
different modalities that
range all the way
from subcellular
to entire human populations.
All these different
modalities that
include DNA, and RNA, and mass
spec, and imaging, and so on.
All of the time scales that are
involved from the subcellular
scales all the way to the scales
of an entire human lifespan.
How do you put
all these together
into a coherent picture
of what makes us age
and what interventions
are the most likely to be
successful in slowing that aging
process and making it better?
So that ability to interpret
the data and make use of it
really requires a
true partnership
between the scientists who
are collecting and getting
intuitions about these
processes and the machine
learning people who
can help construct
models that can synthesize and
put the whole thing together.
And neither of these communities
can be successful on its own.
I was one of the fortunate
people who entered this field
in its very early stages.
So I've been working in the
field of computational biology
since on the early 2000s.
And as such, whereas
you could say
that I am native in the
language of machine learning,
you could say that
I have fluency
in the biological language.
And as such, it
allows me to work
with the scientists
of Calico to create
a true partnership between
those two disciplines
and build models that,
as I mentioned earlier,
is so important to combine the
best of both worlds-- the best
of big data, but also the
best of human intuition.
Because biology's so complex
that I don't think that
even with the amounts of data
that we're collecting today,
we'll be able to reconstruct
biology de novo from data
alone.
You need the data, but you
also need the intuition of some
of the world's best scientists.
And so by working together
at a place like Calico,
we can get some
of those insights
as well as some of the
enormous amounts of data that
are currently being collected.
And I'll come back to that
later to really construct
an in-depth understanding
of the biology of aging
and at the same
time try and predict
which interventions
might be helpful.
DIANE GREENE: Thank you, Daphne.
I feel we should pause.
A lot of profound thinking.
[APPLAUSE]
Hang on to your hats!
We're going to jump
back to vision.
And Fei-Fei, just
the other day, you
were quoted in
TechCrunch as saying,
"Vision is the
killer app of AI."
And so what do you mean by that?
And what does it mean to
democratize AI, and what does
that have to do with the Cloud?
FEI-FEI LI: Yeah, so
yes, I was actually
trying to be provocative,
and I stand by it.
The quote is that, while
many people are asking
for the killer app
of computer vision,
I will say the killer vision
is the killer app of AI.
So let me qualify
that by two reasons.
The first reason
comes from nature.
540 million years ago,
a remarkable event
happened in animal evolution.
For some odd reason, the
number of animal species
went from very
few simple species
to an explosive
increase of the variety
in the types of animals.
It was considered the big bang
of evolution or the Cambrian
explosion.
And the zoologists were
puzzled for many, many decades
about why this happened.
And recently, a very
convincing and prominent theory
conjectured it was
the onset of eyes.
Animal vision.
When eyes were first
developed in animals,
suddenly animal life
became proactive.
There's predators and preys,
and the whole evolution just
changed.
540 million years later,
humans are the most intelligent
visual animals.
In fact, nature devoted
half of our brain
for visual processing
because of its importance.
So that's one thread
of one evidence.
Another piece of evidence comes
from technology and the world
we live in.
If you look at
our internet today
where data is awash,
while YouTube alone
sees 300 plus hours
of the videos uploaded
every single minute, and
it's estimated more than 80%
of the entire cyberspace is
in some kind of pixel form.
And look at the sensors.
The biggest data form
that sensors capture
are in some kind of
images, whether it's
visible spectrum or a spectrum
outside of visible lights.
From biology labs to hospitals,
from self driving cars
to surveillance cameras--
everywhere, the pixel format--
data in pixel format is
the most invaluable data
for consumers and companies.
At Cloud, I had the chance to
talk to a lot of customers.
I have been all about the
demand of image recognition,
video processing,
video analytics.
So it's really an exciting
time for computer vision.
Again, it's just similar
to speech recognition.
Thanks to the progress of
deep neural net, vision
has really taken off as a field
that's made a lot of progress.
In the past 10
years, between 2010--
or seven years-- to 2017, I
would say that the biggest
problems in computer vision is
the basic perception tasks--
object recognition, image
tagging, object detection,
we already have, you see,
products coming out of it--
Google Photos, pedestrian
detection in self-driving cars,
and all this.
But the next
phasing in investing
in computer vision
technology, in my opinion,
is really vision
plus X. Vision is
so fundamental in
communication and language.
How do we speak stories?
How do we tag and index videos?
So the connection and interplay
between vision and language
is going to be
extremely interesting.
Then vision and biological
sciences, whether we're--
the throughput of data coming
from biology, and health care,
and medicine in vision
form is phenomenal.
And be it radiology
or laboratories.
And I think there is a huge
opportunity for vision to play.
And one last example I also
want to give is robotics.
Speaking as a
researcher, there is
a lot of excitement
now happening
in the area of
vision and robotics.
We've been doing robotics for
as long as AI ever existed,
but robots are still
not where they are.
To a large extent, it's because
of its primitive perception
system.
And I think vision
can play a huge role.
So basically, I
do think vision is
one of the most important
elements of machine
intelligence and also for the
transformation of enterprise
and companies.
DIANE GREENE: Thank you.
Great perspective.
[APPLAUSE]
I need to be careful, because
we're running out of time.
So Fernanda, how
does vision help
visualization and visualization
help machine learning?
And maybe to save time,
you could from that
go into where you see
the future of where
you can take the visualization.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Sure.
So yeah, so to piggyback
on Fei-Fei's answer here,
we have this amazingly
sophisticated vision system.
We might as well use it to
understand what these machines
are doing, right?
So machine learning runs on tons
of data, tons of statistics,
and probability.
Well, it turns out that data
visualization can kind of
be a secret weapon in trying
to understand what's happening.
And why do we care?
Why should we care?
We should care because of a
bunch of different reasons.
One is interpretability.
Can you interpret what's
coming out of your models?
Second is debugability.
Better understanding what's
happening with your models
will allow you to
then debug them.
And then finally,
there's also education.
Visualization is already
playing an important role
when it comes to education
about machine learning.
And I also have a
final education piece
there that I'm
very excited about,
which is, when we start
to understand better,
when we use visualization
to understand
better what the
systems are doing,
then can we learn from them?
Can we become better
professionals, better domain
experts in whatever.
If I'm a doctor, if I'm an
architect, whatever it is,
how can I learn from these
very specific systems
and then be better
as a professional?
Another thing about
visualization that I think
is really powerful
and really important
to keep track of is the fact
that by using visualization,
we're always keeping the
human in the loop, right?
And that is huge.
And as we build
autonomous systems,
we want to make sure that
they are behaving well.
And so visualization
can be helpful there.
I want to tell you a very
quick anecdote about a moment--
a scientific moment when
visualization showed us
something we didn't know
before about a machine learning
system.
So last year, Google deployed
its multilingual translate
system, and it was great.
It was this really
exciting moment
of just putting a ton
of different languages
in one system and having the
system somehow figure out how
to translate from every
pair of languages.
The extra bonus was
that it was able to do
what is called zero shot
translation, where it was
able to translate from
pairs of languages
it had not necessarily
seen before.
So one of the
fundamental research
questions that the experts
doing those systems had was,
how is the system resolving
this space of multilingual data?
Is the system creating
something that
looks kind of like a model
over here for English,
and a model over
here for Spanish,
and another one for Portuguese?
Or is the system doing
something very different?
Where it kind of
mixes everything up
in the same spaces,
and it's maybe
learning something
about the semantics
and the meaning of words
and not necessarily
what language it comes
from or what language I'm
translating to?
So what we did is, we
built a visualization
to look into this.
And the really
exciting point was
when we started seeing that--
we visualized sentences that
were being translated into
a bunch of different pairs
of languages.
And the really
exciting thing was
when we saw clusters
of sentences
in these different
languages show up together.
So if I have a sentence that
I'm translating from Portuguese
to Spanish to English
and vice versa,
all of those representations
showed up clustered together.
And then another sentence
here with all the clusters
of all the languages and then--
so in other words,
what did we find out?
We found out that the system
was not partitioning the space
into different languages.
The system was coming up
with a unique representation
of those multiple languages.
So in other words, we
saw the first signs
of a universal
language of something
that we call interlingua.
That was amazing.
And so it was
almost as if we had
ran this multilingual
system through an MRI,
and we're like, whoa!
These are the results this is--
the other thing the
visualization allowed us to do
was to then look
at neighborhoods
that didn't look
very well resolved--
where a little language was
kind of hanging out by itself.
Those were translations
that were not good.
They were not high quality.
So what that tells us is that
the geometry of these spaces
is meaningful.
And if you have your
neighborhood sort
of hanging out in the
periphery by itself,
you might want to look at that.
You might want to make sure
that you debug your system.
So these are kind
of superpowers you
can have in understanding
and making things better,
making things work better.
And for the future,
One of the things
I'm really excited about
sort of goes hand in hand
with something that Fei-Fei I
think is a true advocate for,
is democratizing AI.
Visualization, I think--
and other techniques--
it's not only
visualization, but I truly
believe that the more
different kinds of people
we bring into the fold of
ML, the better off we're
going to be.
Right now, AI still feels
very engineering centric,
and I'm really curious what
will happen when we bring
in designers, UXers,
[? scientists ?] [? says ?]
we're starting to bring in.
What are the different
possibilities?
What are the different solutions
that we haven't even thought
about that we can
then start exploring?
DIANE GREENE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Francoise, I feel
like I should ask you
how's data visualization going
to help speech recognition,
but I also wanted to ask
you about as data gets more
complex, you know, we've
had all this labeled data
for the training models and
we do more personalization,
where's the technology
going and what challenges
are you excited about?
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: Yeah, it's
actually very interesting.
Each time we jump into a new
problem in speech recognition,
we really have to
focus on it in a sense,
you know, when we start
working on YouTube Kids,
for example, which was a
YouTube space for children,
we really had to focus
on those young voices.
They don't speak
the same way we do,
they don't have the
same pitch range,
they don't have the same
way of chopping words.
They take these deep
breaths, and then they
have a burst of speech.
So we really had to focus on it.
And then eventually,
we found a way
of folding back that learning
into our generic models
so that Google
Home, for example,
would work with your children
as well as it does with you.
But Google Home itself was
also a new environment where
we had to collect new data.
And when that data
is available to you,
then it's easy to fold it into
the models and keep retraining.
But the first time you want to
launch a Google Home device,
you don't have it, right?
And so we did a
lot of simulations
taking data, adding
noise of different types,
doing different types of
reverberation on the data,
and indeed, we use
massive amounts of data.
We transcribe tens of
thousands of hours of speech
and then we multiply it
with the simulations.
If you do the math, it
averages to something
like a handful of
centuries of speech
that we can fold into a model,
so just massive amounts.
And I think it's
very interesting
to think about how that
scales to more problems
with different acoustic
characteristics,
but also to different languages.
If I can ask you guys, like
you know how many of you
speak another
language than English?
Right, you see?
All the hands are raising.
So we really want to make our
technology available to all
of you in your own language.
And if you think of it,
it's a massive problem.
How are we going to do that?
Are we going to build
one recognizer that
works for all of you?
Are we going to do like we
do now, one per language?
Well, how about dialects, then?
And how are we
going to do when we
have a language that's a fairly
small one with small pocket
of individuals?
So if you ask linguists,
they will tell you
that there are 6,000, 7,000
languages in the world.
They will tell you that there
are about 1,000 of them--
actually, 1,342, they say,
that have more than 100,000
speakers.
So that's a lot, right?
And if we want to really go
into deep internationalization
and serve all the languages that
have big populations on earth,
it's going to require
a lot of creativity
on the machine learning
side to manage to share data
among languages, learn
from other languages,
and so on So I think
it's really exciting
and there is still a ton of
work to do in that domain.
DIANE GREENE: I agree.
It's a very exciting.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
We're going to go a
little over, so we
have time to hear about the
future from Fei-Fei and Daphne.
Fei-Fei, what excites you about
what's possible going forward?
FEI-FEI LI: What
excites me about what's
possible going forward?
Let me just say one dimension.
I generally believe AI
is one of the driving
forces of the fourth
industrial revolution.
It's just the beginning,
but it has the potential
to transform the way humans
live, work, and communicate.
And one favorite line I
heard from a philosopher
is, there's no independent
machine values.
Machine values are human values.
So one thing that
really excites me
is to include the
diverse technologists
in the field of AI to
build the future together.
Because once we have that
diversity of representation
in the field of
AI technology, we
will build the technology that
is for the entire humanity,
not just a slice of it.
DIANE GREENE: Yes, you
have a lot of credibility
when you say that, Fei-Fei.
[APPLAUSE]
And Daphne, the
intersection of biology,
and computing, and everything
else you've done, what--
DAPHNE KOLLER: Well, when
I look at the progress
that machine learning has made
over the last five to 10 years,
and as a long time AI
researcher, if you'd
asked me even five years
ago, will computers
be able to caption
images without any kind
of prior knowledge,
just in the same quality
that a human would, I would have
said, nehh, maybe in 20 years.
And with the work of
Fei-Fei and others,
we've been able to reach
that milestone way sooner
than I would have expected.
The reason I moved back
to biology from Coursera
is because I think
we're hitting that knee
in the curve in biology.
So when you look,
for instance, at some
of the current
predictions, there
was a paper that was published
in 2015 called "Big Data--
Astronomical or Genomical?"
And it looks at the number of
human genome sequence, which
is a very limited part
of biological data that's
being captured, and you look
at the historical trend,
and that amount
doubles every seven
months, which makes it about
twice as fast as Moore's law.
So if you look at 2025
and you project that line,
the number of human
genome sequence by 2025
will be on the conservative
projection, 100 million,
and if you look at
the historical trend,
it'll be two billion.
Two billion human
genome sequence,
and that's just sequence.
That doesn't count RNA, and
proteomes, and whole body
imaging, and cellular imaging.
So we're at the cusp
of the beginnings,
I think, of really understanding
what is the most complex system
that we've encountered, which
is that of a biological system.
What is it that makes us alive?
What is it that
forces us to die?
And so I think with that amount
of data and the techniques
that machine learning has
developed and will continue
to develop, we
have an opportunity
to really transform
science in this way.
And I'm really excited to
be able to bring those two
communities together
to make that possible.
[APPLAUSE]
DIANE GREENE: So there's
clearly so much more
that we could sit
and listen to here.
This has just been
a phenomenally
interesting and inspiring panel.
Thank you very much.
FEI-FEI LI: Thank you, Diane.
[APPLAUSE]